Many movie stars don't have to pretend
to be badasses on the big screen because
they're already badasses in real life! From
martial arts masters to decorated war heroes,
here are the most badass actors past and present.
From his un-shaveable beard
to his unstoppable boot,
the real Chuck Norris is even more
badass than the legendary one.
Born Carlos Ray Norris in 1940 in Ryan, Oklahoma,
Norris began training in the martial art form of
Tang Soo Do and Judo while serving in the United
States Air Force in South Korea in the late 1960s.
Norris won the world middleweight
karate championship six years in
a row. He even founded his own style, a
Korean-American hybrid called Chun Kuk Do,
now known as "the Chuck Norris System."
Among his other real-life feats is
training badass Steve McQueen in karate,
"I saw a movie called On Any Sunday. I said if
there's any one actor I'd like to
meet, that's the man I'd like to meet."
"And so Steve became one of my private students."
Chuck Norris also had his own line of "Action
Jeans," and was the first Westerner to earn the
rank of eighth-degree black belt grandmaster in
Taekwondo. Norris hasn't lost a fight since 1968.
The father of Western martial arts films,
Bruce Lee gave us some epic fight scenes.
But his big screen adventures weren't the result
of special effects — Lee was the real deal.
And let's be honest: He probably would have kicked
Brad Pitt's ass in Once Upon A Time in Hollywood.
While Bruce Lee was born in San Francisco in
1940, he became a child actor in Hong Kong,
where he also began training in
Kung Fu. Lee returned to the U.S.,
attending the University of Washington and
eventually opening a martial arts school.
While Lee is best remembered for being
a pioneering Asian-American movie star
who brought Kung Fu movies to American audiences,
he was also a once-in-a-generation martial artist,
both onscreen and off. Bruce Lee developed
his own style called Jeet Kune Do,
or "Way of the Intercepting Fist".
Famously, he could even knock a man down with one-
and six-inch punches. Bruce Lee died in his early
30s from cerebral edema.
Ronda Rousey's filmography may
not have any Oscar contenders,
but who needs to collect awards when
your nickname is "The Arm Collector"?
As a child, Rousey fell in love with Judo. In
2004, she competed in her first Olympics in
Athens when she was just 17. Rousey returned four
years later to Beijing, winning the Bronze medal.
She moved on to mixed martial arts,
becoming the female standard bearer
for the Ultimate Fighting Championship,
winning the women's bantamweight belt
and racking up a UFC record of 6-2,
and 12-2 for her total MMA career.
A badass in the making, Rousey
brought mainstream attention
and millions of eyeballs to women's fighting,
and she made herself a major star in the process.
In addition to her movie roles, Rousey is
also a professional wrestler with the WWE,
and she made history participating in the first
women's match main event at WrestleMania 35.
Born Phillip Andre Rourke Jr. in Schenectady,
New York, Mickey Rourke is not only a celebrated
actor, he's also got a devastating right hook.
Rourke was throwing punches long before he
was reciting lines, racking up an impressive
27-3 record, with 17 victories by knockout,
as an amateur boxer in the 1960s and 1970s.
The fighter returned to the ring after
establishing himself as a thespian,
and then he returned again in 2014,
at age 62, fighting Elliot Seymour,
a 29-year old former California
state Golden Gloves champion.
Rourke knocked Seymour down twice
before the referee stopped the fight
and awarded the win to Rourke. Seymour,
however, claims he took a dive.
Whether or not the fight was fixed,
there's no denying that Rourke,
an Oscar-nominated actor for The
Wrestler, is badass on and off screen.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson is one of the most
popular movie stars in Hollywood. Before he was
swinging from vines in the Jumanji series, revving
18-wheelers in The Fast and The Furious movies,
or flexing his massive biceps on Instagram,
the Rock was doing all kinds of badass stuff.
For one thing, Johnson was a successful pro
wrestler. He was also a college athlete,
playing defensive lineman for the National
Championship-winning Miami Hurricanes.
Unfortunately for the Rock, he played the
same position as arguably the greatest
defensive linemen ever, Warren Sapp.
When Johnson asked Sapp what he was
doing in the defensive linemen
locker room, Sapp told Johnson,
"I'm here for your job, b---h."
And that's exactly what he did. Warren
Sapp became a NFL Hall of Famer,
and Dwayne Johnson is, well, the Rock.
"When this whole thing's over we're gonna find
a location and I'm gonna knock your teeth so
far down your throat you're gonna stick a
toothbrush right up your ass to brush them."
Arnold Schwarzenegger practically invented the
modern action hero genre that defined the 1980s.
After all, he was a one-man army in
films like The Terminator, Predator,
Total Recall, The Running Man, and Commando.
But you don't take down thousands of bad guys
without breaking a sweat if you're not a badass.
Schwarzenegger built his larger-than-life legend
one curl, crunch, squat and press at a time.
Arnold Alois Schwarzenegger
was born in Austria in 1947,
but he dreamed of coming to America
and saw bodybuilding as his ticket.
He racked up an incredible list of accomplishments
in bodybuilding, including seven Mr. Olympias.
Schwarzenegger also served
as governor of California,
so there's that. For being the literal
definition of a self-made man and one of
the most accomplished competitors in his sport's
history, Schwarzenegger is definitely a badass.
Most movie stars would consider themselves
lucky to play one iconic big screen hero.
Harrison Ford has played two — Indiana
Jones and Han Solo. Ford's heroic roles
are so memorable that he placed twice in the
top 15 on AFI's 100 greatest heroes list,
with the rugged wise-cracking
archaeologist ranking #2.
"I hate snakes, Jock! I hate 'em!"
Throw in Rick Deckard from Blade Runner,
Dr. Richard Kimble from The Fugitive, and
Jack Ryan from the Tom Clancy
series, and Harrison Ford has
plenty of unforgettable moments and characters
that put him in the badass hall of fame.
However, Ford has proven the best way to be
a big screen hero is to be one in real life.
A trained airplane and helicopter pilot,
"You ever have a flying dream? I have …”
Harrison Ford has come to the rescue
of several people in danger. In 2000,
he saved two hikers who got stranded at
the top of Table Mountain in Wyoming.
The very next year, he rescued a 13-year old
Boy Scout who got separated from his troop.
Talk about a badass! Must be nice having
Indiana Jones come to your rescue!
“I told you! Don't call me Junior!"
Sir Christopher Lee is known for playing some
of cinema's most diabolical villains, including
Dracula, Saruman, and Francisco Scaramanga,
aka one of the most iconic Bond villains.
While nobody was better at being bad in movies,
Christopher Lee was a good guy in real life.
And he took on some of history's worst villains.
Born in 1922, Lee served the Finnish in the
Winter War against the Soviet Union in 1939.
He joined the Royal Air Force in 1940
and served in the Long Range Desert Group
during World War II, where he fought behind
enemy lines and destroyed German aircraft.
Lee kept quiet about his service
well into his later years, saying,
"I was attached to the SAS from time to time, but
we are forbidden — former, present, or future — to
discuss any specific operations. Let's just say
I was in Special Forces and leave it at that."
As if all this isn't badass enough, Lee
also set a Guinness World Record in 2007
for the most screen credits for a living
actor, 244 film and TV movies. On a long
list full of certifiable badasses,
Sir Christopher Lee may be king.
Only a badass can go from inmate to
action star! A Los Angeles native,
Danny Trejo became a criminal at an early
age, getting tossed into juvie after
hitting a kid with a rock. And
he wasn't a one-time offender.
"When you're on a CDC bus it's the only bus on
the freeway. Everybody knows you're a criminal."
He spent his teen years as the
getaway driver for his robber uncle,
and he even stabbed a sailor with a broken bottle.
When Trejo was busted for selling
"heroin" to an undercover agent,
though it was actually just sugar,
he was sent to prison. He became
a celebrity in the slammer for his
boxing prowess, telling TMZ Sports,
"I was lightweight and welterweight
champion of every penitentiary I was in,
and I was in all of them."
Trejo did stints in San Quentin, Folsom,
and Soledad. But his background behind
bars isn't what makes him a
badass — it's his redemption.
The actor turned his life around, earning his high
school diploma in prison and serving as
a drug counselor after being released.
For fighting and conquering his
demons, Trejo is a badass with merit!
Actor Audie Murphy is the most highly
decorated soldier in American military history.
Murphy was born in Texas in 1925, and he helped
raise his 11 brothers and sisters after his
father abandoned the family, dropping out of
the fifth grade to earn money as a sharecropper.
Following the bombing of
Pearl Harbor on December 7,
1941, Audie Murphy falsified his age and
joined the Army at 17 years old in 1942.
Murphy's most courageous act was mounting
an abandoned, burning tank destroyer and
with a single machine gun taking on six
German Panzer tanks and 250 infantrymen.
Even more heroic:
Audie Murphy single-handedly stopped the
enemy advance, which allowed him to lead
his men in driving the Germans from
Holtzwihr in 1945. He was that badass!
After the war's end, Murphy was discovered by
movie star James Cagney and began a successful
film career in Westerns. Murphy's high point as
an actor was playing himself in To Hell and Back,
though he wanted the story to reflect the
experience of all infantrymen, not just himself.
Murphy said:
"I've always felt their story should
be told. I just play a part in it."
Before he was battling Klingons as Scotty,
the chief engineer of the USS Enterprise,
James Doohan was fighting Nazis
in Europe during World War II.
Despite his famous Scottish accent, Doohan was
actually Canadian, and when WWII broke out,
he joined the Royal Canadian Artillery
and was shipped to England in 1940.
Doohan went years without seeing conflict,
training for an eventual invasion of Europe.
When D-Day finally arrived on June 6, 1944,
Doohan was a key part of the Normandy invasion,
single-handedly taking out two German
snipers without getting a single scratch!
However, Doohan didn't leave the war unscathed.
He took four shots in the legs and chest when a
Canadian soldier mistook him for a German and
opened fire. Remarkably, the chest bullet was
stopped by a cigarette case. But one bullet shot
off Doohan's middle finger on his right hand.
Following the war, Doohan had dreams of
pursuing a technical or scientific career,
but when he heard awful voice acting on
the radio, he said he could do better.
And a Star Trek icon was born.
"I may be captain by rank. But I never
wanted to be anything else but an engineer."
Mel Brooks is behind some of the funniest
comedies of all time — Blazing Saddles,
Young Frankenstein, The Producers,
Spaceballs, the list goes on.
Despite his reputation as one of
America's most successful funnymen,
Brooks' military career is no laughing matter.
Born Melvin Kaminsky in 1926 in Brooklyn, Brooks
was drafted into World War II. While overseas,
the man of comedy served as corporal in the 1104th
Engineer Combat Battalion, 78th Infantry Division.
His job title was combat engineer and
one of his duties was defusing landmines.
Yup! We'd say he's a bonafide badass!
Brooks also fought in the Battle of the
Bulge, a German counteroffensive that was
halted by Allied forces, effectively
stopping the Nazis in their tracks.
Despite seeing the horrors of the
Nazis up close in World War II,
when Brooks came home, he figured the best way
to fight Nazi tyranny was by ridiculing them.
Brooks' The Producers is perhaps best
known for the absurd musical number
"Springtime for Hitler," which makes a
mockery of his old wartime adversaries.
Don't let his folksy demeanor and all-around nice
guy status fool you — Jimmy Stewart was a badass.
Born in Pennsylvania in 1908, James
Stewart studied architecture at Princeton,
and launched a successful acting
career on Broadway and in Hollywood.
Despite being one of the brightest young
stars of the day — including his nomination
for an Oscar in 1939 for Mr. Smith Goes to
Washington and winning an Oscar in 1941 for The
Philadelphia Story — Stewart was drafted into
the Army in 1941 and didn't seek a deferment.
In fact, when the Army said
he was too skinny to serve,
Stewart gained weight to make sure he'd qualify.
Jimmy Stewart became a pilot in the Army
Air Force, ending his war service with
20 combat missions and rising to the rank of
colonel. He remained in the United States Air
Force Reserve and was eventually promoted
to the rank of brigadier general in 1959.
His accolades include two Distinguished Flying
Crosses and the Presidential Medal of Freedom.
"So we are very proud to be here
and we're going to do our best to be useful as
soldiers for the United States Army. Thank you."
Stewart was not only the nicest
guy in Hollywood history,
he was the highest-ranking
actor in military history.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.